assalamu aleikum wa rahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys doing well yeah
so basically we're on the way to permit
them we're working basically as we was
growing there you've been happy for did
oh yeah that's it that's it muscle just
in a story over some sister that he
knows that chrome came in religion
really fast and then a funny yeah so
came to the religion really fast and now
has basically is going through some
trials and kind of going back to their
old ways be here so now before when he
said that then after huge game will have
you right oh yeah so we for you know
this actually big problem reason being
is because this is you have a trend you
have this my personal thing is we have
this trend where we have young people
who have lived journey or whatever it
may be and they take a big nose dive to
Islam intentions are good it's not that
I do wanna do anything bad but what
happened is they go into the cycle of
quality piety at me and goes a whole
other fight itself unit yeah so what it
means you just go for this face with you
just night
yeah you wear the for my son is so good
nobody's ever complain about that what
you actions are good and what you want
to do is good but however if I'm second
one is to have all the mean the time
being somebody said that a lot of people
start with good intentions but I know of
them achieved now this cycle is
basically coming extra religious going
in trying to do everything you can in
the religion what happens if I hear all
guns blazing and this also comes with a
judgment to you stop judging people you
start looking down on people you start
acting a certain way do I'm trying to
say and
it has an impact on you you know and
it's a negative impact was weapons when
you overburden yourself and this happens
with some people do it with their outer
garment this time went in the Carm
straight way some bubbles do this and
the next thing you know like forth mom's
done about five months and then a year
some two months everything comes off and
then you see it yourself where did it go
wrong here so briefly just can you just
tell us about the hobby so let's go
forward I actually - Louise and
what about the long on having to be
smart about 90 days so that slightly the
religion is ease yeah so he's here
suggests a las botanas he's mention the
Quran he wants he wants our lives to be
easy here easily you need love what are
you read so lost fantastic Rhonda he
wants is for you in it doesn't want
hardship for you which is a very
important attitude that Islamic model
has for two individuals yeah that we is
not intended for us that would go
through hardship intended first that we
go through a hard time in the religion
it's meant to be actually a thing that
facilitates for us in this the world and
Hereafter
so in the Dniester certainly the
religion is peace okay so that's why
it's meant by and to be honest with you
if you look at eleven last I'm gonna
slowly have a sunny hat are the few good
things the ones I had actually just
means the few cool things because it's
cool jameelah we have elephant and tear
at the end of it so the few good things
are a lot telling us to do like the five
pillars and these things they're not
actually time-consuming and that energy
consuming so the Dean generally speaking
in the context in the grand scheme of
things in the context of our life is
actually easy
the religion is easy all you have to do
in terms of action and exertion of
energies and time is all you have to do
is a few things according to the chronic
discourse so you mentioned the five
pillars yeah is that is that core
fundamentals evolution so the five
pillars of Islam or C so it's really a
sword on to me shelter later they were
working on solo and Palmisano returns
again 50s this country
you don't get stuck yeah anyway she had
this Allah except Allah Tezuka Osamu
done - yes understand yeah yes if you
think about a lot of these pillars
manually done like Jessica is annually
done you have to pay money to charity
the Hajj is ultimately one so has once
in a lifetime so saw was once a year
once annually done Shahada is done once
this is done once yeah
Jesus to was a year two sentences that
you say in Arabic one time and then you
have to pray a prayer which is the most
probably consistent thing you do yeah it
was five times a day and even that if
you think about it I mean how long is he
little really take me a day about half
an hour
exactly you know so it's not yeah I
don't need that you know the Bedouin man
who came to prophet of Solomon and he
said oh man what can I do to be able to
really said you know the the Shahada and
they tell me I'll do the shot I said
then what must I do say then please
arise that I'll do this around I've been
one of the quest then I said is the
character of a except that you were five
said nothing more nothing less
fasting Ramadan is about it fast exactly
in Ramadan nothing into nothingness and
go ahead if you have the means to and
when the man walked away the prophet
called pointed at him and the companions
were there he said he follow this man
you'll be successful so what it shows is
by default that this is the main thing
that when its cultural and I've seen it
for major sins and also another thing I
was speaking to one brother here you
just asked me a question about you know
a key why why did Allah was er you know
just got a bit more yeah safety first
always
now that was not big enough but anyways
here and can we say by default allow us
one's gender for us yeah exactly yeah by
default this how do you think but yes so
yeah yeah a lot is one of the what what
will allow again from punishing you yeah
images that no yeah so why don't you
share that well let me share that team I
had a love Allah Allah never in love
Oliver the day no one basically consumes
too much of all basically of appearances
and overburdens himself or herself with
the religion except that the religious
the religion overburdening what do you
what do you mean what do we get by them
because some people I say you know what
I'm practicing what was wrong with me
dr. Stidham do an extra well there's
nothing wrong with that in fact that's
encouraged what we're becomes work
becomes actually becomes County soil
becomes basically a burden amongst and
for you yeah do you know I'm saying so
what you know there is a saying in
Arabic and there's also hadith the best
deeds yeah yeah
are those would you do small but
consistent me rather than highly endemic
is there more katana if you do something
small but consistently it's better than
doing something which is big
inconsistent so like can we say if
somebody said you know okay I'm gonna
we're gonna cut that already for and
then they end up taking it all off that
languages it's a bit stable its Tiffany
job anymore it depends on the opinion
that person follows [ __ ] yeah generally
speaking if that person follows the
opinion
that the hands and the face of the only
things I need to be covered shown we
have me shown then that could be an
example but also the example of lack say
for example a yes if you want okay I'm
Elaine if for example doing it every
single day or doing it a lot for a
couple of days like say for example
doing like one hour one hour and a half
for two or three days over a week it's
not as good as doing it they said twenty
five minutes every day yeah you get it
so things like that you're gonna take
the insert by the way yeah yeah what's
up so since you've spoken to this sister
I thought of it to multiple people your
judgment was your suitability but the
thing is yeah we need to understand is
that firstly as you know from the many
many things mentioned we know that the
Dean is supposed to be easy for us if
you're making it hard on yourself then
there's a problem that's the first thing
secondly the hadith the Ali mentioned is
very very relevant to what we're talking
about
a lien sale I'd imagine it's the one
that you mentioned you oh but you little
mark the man yes said that he will do
the things that Islam requires of him
nothing more nothing less
and what did the prophet saw the loudest
and I'm saying response to that that
this man he will enter general if he
actually does what he said yeah of
course now what do we take from that
what we take from that is that just by
you doing your application and trying to
adhere to the Sunnah yeah that's enough
now what the problem is is that when
some of us become practicing we fall in
love with the team there's nothing wrong
with that we should be falling in love
with the beam is beautiful yeah where
the problem comes in is that when we
young we have a tendency to become
overzealous very quickly so when will
they come overzealous why actually ends
up happening is you're like wow this is
amazing I love this I want to pray okay
you know what I can break down my Laila
I've heard about that as well let me
pray camel eight okay memorizing Quran
Quran is beautiful let me memorize it
you start memorizing Quran itself back
to these classes he starts doing
everything and what what has happened
here within the space of a week what's
happened is he's gone from
a lifestyle or maybe going she shot
maybe not too extreme what not chilly
chillin out with his friends to
completely within a week become innocent
of knowledge it's a big transition to
make now the problem of that transition
is because you haven't built yourself up
to it the foundations eventually ability
roof you have yourself up to it so now
what's going to happen is when you're
deep into it and something hits you all
the Semana toilet tissue something
you're gonna basically what I'm saying
is yeah you know when you're overwhelmed
that's where there is a deciding point
some people when they're overwhelmed
they can break through but many many
people and most people they will fall
off this is way to spoke to one person
what I was going through a specific
problem this personal knowledge he spoke
to me he said you know what you don't
realize is that think about this that's
a long one peaceful you're putting
yourself in this problem there's a love
what this from you and what is in one
district that's really good so if a lot
doesn't want is from you why are you
doing it to yourself and you know you
know I think you know what's really
crucial is this is not to say just
saying
no look I'm not once if we say to people
look do this LaRhonda
is put but what they fall into a mistake
is is that now you know yourself
personally here but what happens is a
lot of Orientalism when you take your
matches of righteousness and piety that
you try to become and now start judge
judging now what you do is you gain
other people involved and sometimes that
has a big backlash they said
specifically if you're let's say your
YouTube all you have a social problem
that's a bigger problem cuz you know
what's gonna happen you're going to be
stuck in a very bad dynamo because when
you start off with practice and practice
and afters in advising people even maybe
not refuting them have been harsh on
them to stop when you are tested with
fitna now you're at a crossroad because
you're like okay now I want to treat
this image if I've done this now I'm
going through a chest I need to maintain
it what am I going to do now you're in
the Dynamo try carry on when I cut
because I'm being tested when I fall off
what are people gonna say now you're in
style Emma now if you do this to
yourself and you're practicing in the
doing it their photos that you have is
between you and Allah but when you go on
this thing of where you are start
judging people and doing this what
happens is now when we follow people
gonna die what happened yeah you get it
it makes you it over burdens you even
more not just a religion but now people
are gonna be like ah you're the same guy
he was going to no matter what nobody
would do it now now in overburdens you
want now if you like any but now you're
not yeah man look how I was before it's
no point you get it and the shades on
comes so it's better for you to do what
you're doing but it's better it's for
you to do in a private setting
judgmental and work on yourself and I
think this reason why a lot of people
fall into this by nose-diving
Algy I'm happy to give my own personal
example in this year a lot of brothers
around me they're practicing like
yourself like yourself like many other
brothers as water hanging around someone
approach sometimes you'll be going to a
lot of classes and sometimes they'll
push me to go to these classes there's
one specific problem a Allah may Allah
bless him he pushes me to come to his
class and then he doesn't know what I
was trying to do people aren t he
doesn't know I'm trying to do currently
yeah so I told him I'm here right now
I've put my studying focus on what
specific topic I'm focusing on that now
I know myself if I start going into that
and that you know this main topic I'm
focusing on I'm going to lose that and
everything yes so now what I choose to
do is in my head even if the prophets
are great suppose I might come with them
but my main focus currently is one
dismiss because like for example Quran
or what of him once I've done that then
I'll go to the next one so don't ever
think that you need to be on the same
level as your friends yeah it's not
necessary yeah make sure you set targets
in your own mind for a specific thing
and do that by the way another
clarification which I think we should
clarify I'm sure we all agree on this
year we're not talking about obligatory
acts like Salaam yeah so like something
you should be doing a couple is a I'm
often burden in myself I should know
sorry
yeah
don't start saying oh you know I sort of
embedded we're talking about exception
and we're talking about we're talking
about family you know extra fasting
sometimes these things do wearing a for
outside wearing a yes yes like this ring
this overly pious image here of doing
extra dates when you don't need to do
them right now but it's always young
serious people now the thing is what is
this one is the sooner that you go for
you wouldn't have it would never be
faced with a decision of two different
things
except that he chose a Sarang the
easiest of the two this is by the way
like okay so some scholars
I've set that for example this would
apply if there are two opinions of Islam
that you've got like opinion a opinion
being you know you've gone on which that
it maybe they'll both within a method
that you follow whatever
and and one of the opinions is harder
one of the pins is easier you don't know
how to distinguish between those two
opinions so what's the submitted it so
according to some scholars you go go for
the easy you should go for the easier
option why this easier cuz it's a Sunnah
of the Prophet and also because they
goes back to this hadith innocence right
so and that this kind of thinking is
important in the Western context in the
Western context some say no is better
chance to be more safe than sorry
and there's the hadith of mine
appreciate everyone
elevator so many
the hell honestly and harem is clear
distributed by Fremantle is this true
value
yeah so there are not many people know
them so keep away from the grain matches
and 12-hour fools integrate matches
cousins in Sahara and everything if
there's something this is the second
point you know there's two things one if
this elegy my opinion within the Sunni
Islamic framework
yeah and it's legit as one of the school
for schools or for opinions or something
like this yeah then anyone has a right
to vote
no one can sell can you turn wrong and
by the way there's a difference between
our commanders when they can you know
that this is something a lot of people
use some people use areas were not
formally yeah
but tomorrow for the handloom cup its
idea of commanding to the good and
fulfilling to the evening gap and there
is a difference between a moral model
from the hammock our number of our roof
is for best telling people to do good
which can include it can include
something which is where gym which
include solution was to happen so for
example if I tell someone you know you
should read the front this is operable
models no doubt yeah but if that person
says I don't want to read if I'm right
now you can't say well you're doing
wrong here because this is naked monk
are there are poker is forbidding the
evil so a number of our off and they had
one or two different things
and now ya lamu car is when you're
explicitly forbidding against the evil
okay and when we say one car there has
to be a something which all of the
Muslims agree upon for example drinking
for example doing something like a
sinner whenever all of these things are
things which all the Muslims agree upon
hearing so if someone says okay what you
know I believe is for you but that's
what a bit but another thing is on top
of the homilies where the handle is they
said I for example the purpose for a lot
of them had a lot of other people now a
woman that's worse than a cop can turn
around that's not a family Allison what
you're doing is Monica what you're doing
is evil they are no worse than a class
on the club's first according to you
yeah okay it's according to your school
of law is fine that is energy my opinion
you can follow but entourage so a woman
is not worried about and say it's fun
basically exactly where there is a laugh
Muhammad which means that is a
legitimate difference of opinion you're
not allowed here legitimate if that
doesn't mean that you bring start
bringing some guy while sitting here
saying in Egypt you know in the exact
unit saying so just my advice would you
give to youngsters Howard gives
youngsters the following advice yeah
personally I would say first and
foremost if you're fortunate religiously
competitor if you if you're going on the
treadmill you've never run before if
you've ever had very limited experience
with running you you want to put it on
it on the level where you can maintain
pace
so if you--if you jump on the treadmill
and this one like the 14 be able to run
I'm gonna say you're a high five say for
how long there's a question you might
fall off my fly off so the religion is
passing my life if you go into the
religion with all of it so then you go
on the treadmill and you fly off the
treadmill together
that's the fighting now judgment
remember one golden piece of advice yeah
just because you are told is Haram and
now there lots of things that the
Muslims generally speaking every day is
Haram it's very clear
things like shell things like cover
things like drinking alcohol things like
Xena etc these things that definitely
Haram good edge man yeah everyone agrees
is Haram however those things which are
which are potential there is a
Hellespont about which literally there
is a difference of opinion which is
regarded legitimately within the city
school for if someone follows us there
an opinion from any of those without him
or whatever
leave them alone you can't tell them
what they're doing is wrong do not do
that because that could itself be wrong
yes I'll leave the people alone if
they're doing something which is legit
which has a strong scholarly backing me
people
because at the end of the day and the
beta's good example of that debate is a
perfect example of that yeah let's say
there are three or four main opinions to
build one of them is to leave a complete
okay so one of the appraisal is the key
to leave a completely the Hiller million
is to have it like Albanian lovers like
having 151 our denomination is
dissipating the third opinion is to have
a Qatif is the gay yeah it's just kind
of think okay and this is distinguished
as a lie here okay
another opinion is some chef has been
going from event happening now the point
is this if you see anyone doing any of
those things
say for example you take the first
opinion that the invaders should be left
you see someone for bait that's just
like for you see in some other way
there's even less than 50 we're gonna
say to them you just say oh it is one
cup that would that would make you that
would make you not appreciative of the
scholarly opinion Arabic it's actually
could you toss our reasons if you know
it yeah so things like that I would say
yeah and also you talked about the shape
that yes sometimes you say dog
additional one is on 14 but then you
have people of influence who are on
level 14 and they gain new people and
put them under a treadmill
yeah this is another problem because
what are you doing is you're you're not
feeding them snow you don't attend the
volcano too slowly
what are you doing it just because
you're on a certain level you're looking
down on if you want them to be on it
they own it but don't forget where you
can turn it is really important because
then you advising people the wrong thing
and people are jumping on board one and
a mud one and the next thing you know
they're falling off you know some of
these people yeah they will when they
start practicing they would be listening
to certain speakers rappers now that
they're up they will say to all of the
young kids don't listen to these guys
yeah when these guys are the ones that
we do practices so it's like everyone
has a let everyone be on their journey
everyone's on their journey don't make
the religion harder but one thing that
because these guys they'll take it and
they'll run without that Oh Susan
anyways yes well we just wanted to show
you
let's review guys that look Allah wants
gender for you the the religions come
yet not to overburden you to make your
life easy and it's best the reason why
Allah sent is message on traveling we're
traveling to Recaro if Ally said this is
the religion to make life easy you are
actually opposing that by making a
hundred new so that's about it guys hope
you guys a benefit to our community
take care guys it from all these
discussion conversations let me know